Aneta Templin has been fighting for her
inheritance for more than two decades it
comprises valuable works of art by pearl
clay and piet mondrian and has led to
numerous meetings with her leipzig
lawyer anita temple ins grandmother was
art collector sophie Lissitzky cooper's
in 1927 when Nazism was beginning to
take root in Germany she followed her
husband to the Soviet Union
she left her collection to a museum in
Hannover unlearn but the Nazis dubbed it
degenerate art and seized it anita
Templin wants her grandmother's looted
art back first and foremost this is
about justice but it's also about not
letting someone simply say oh well the
pictures are gone because my grandmother
had to fight her entire life and did
fight and would still be fighting hard
for her pictures I just want to see
justice restored and see everything
returned to its rightful place some of
the pictures could be in the collection
owned by Cornelius Gurlitt for decades
he stashed some 1,400 works of art in
his Munich apartment nobody knew about
the treasure which experts estimate
could be worth as much as thirty million
euros Gurlitt inherited the pictures
from his father who was a Nazi appointed
art dealer
the public prosecutor seized the
collection but kept the find a secret
for more than a year the international
community has responded with outrage to
the revelation about the hoard of
suspected Nazi looted art and rightly so
says inheritance lawyer Gayle Costello
over the decades more has been done to
cover-up deny and blatantly lie than has
been done to settle the issue of looted
art and I'm talking about all levels of
involvement our dealers museums and
private collections as well Costel
represents the heirs of MUX Lieberman
numerous pieces by the Jewish artists
that were long considered lost turned up
in girl it's apartment but it's unlikely
that the heirs will get their works back
from private collectors and foundations
because there's a 30 year statute of
limitations in Germany on stolen art
what that means is that theoretically
the current owner can say the original
owners no longer have any claim to the
work for state museums there is a moral
duty to do the right thing Germany
signed a declaration under which works
of art stolen by the Nazis should be
returned to their owners seeing that as
their chance Meniere's turned to
historian at Monica Tut's go for help
she is looking for 4,000 pieces of
looted art in museums worldwide but in
Germany many doors remain closed to her
- of foil patient strangely and
interestingly my research experience in
European countries is very different in
Switzerland for example I have not yet
met with any restrictions in Zurich
squinched house I'm granted access to
all the documents I want to see the same
goes for the Netherlands where there are
no research limitations for Shenzhen
Shane :
Anita Templin and her lawyer hope the
girl is find will change things and
encourage collectors both state and
private to reach agreements with heirs
like temple in many have been fighting
for decades for their families works of
art I think many have already given up
but I'm sure there are also others who
don't even know there are works of art
that once belonged to their families
even if there seems to be some progress
in the realm of looted art the Gurdit
case underscores the fact that there is
a long way to go let's fish boats
fishing for melimeli there's a major
discrepancy between the law and moral
legitimation in my view the German
parliament has to tackle this problem
and try to come up with a ruling that
solves it properly collect in Ahmedabad
and Kanna
every week pictures from the girl it
find are published on a database many
potential owners have already made
contact but girl it is not volunteering
to give up his treasures isaiah dozen
linked I very much hope that the Federal
Republic of Germany the state of Bavaria
whoever is responsible
reaches a sensible understanding with
mr. Gortat
it can't be that in playing stubborn an
old man does further damage and that we
fail to find a reasonable solution
that's a problem and younger mr. luzhin
con anita Templin has received
information to suggest one of her
family's paintings could be in the
Gurlitt collection she plans to continue
fighting for its return she owes it she
says to her grandmother